something interesting is happening here
we all get everyone gets that this thing
is a disaster but the media is starting
to finally talk about it a year and a
half in they're starting to mention the
cognitive stuff they're starting to
blame him for things and believe it or
not it's even making it to cnn he's in
charge at this moment that's bleak
that's right and and there's no question
that in some big ways this
administration including the president
and some of his closest economic
advisers got inflation wrong we've heard
that correction from some of his top
officials including the treasury
secretary janet yellen saying yeah last
year when we were saying this is
probably going to be temporary and
transitory we were wrong
jedidiah you used to be on the view that
is
mainstream media and god bless you for
sitting at that table by the way um it's
it's happening i mean it's bursting
forth into the mainstream they cannot
ignore this much longer right
yeah and i survived the view so thank
you for that dave but you know here's
the thing i think that
i think they're setting us all up though
they're gonna have to cart somebody else
out here that's not biden listen i'm
sorry he can't do this again he knows he
can't do it again his family his friends
the people close to him know he can't do
this again especially if he's going to
be up against someone like ron desantis
who is the guy to ron we can get to that
in a second but i think they're setting
it up like they're going to ease in and
try to say well joe biden may have done
this wrong they'll turn on him in two
seconds if it means that it's going to
be cackling kamala or it's going to be
somebody else that they pull out of the
woodwork i don't know pete mayor pete
who knows who it's going to be it could
be beto for all we know where these
people are headed but i think they're
going to have to ease us into that and
you're going to see a slow at first and
then quicker transition where people are
going to start to turn on biden from
within the camp because they know that
he cannot get up to the podium listen in
a couple of years he's not going to be
able to get up to the podium he can't
even do it now he phases out
mid-sentence oftentimes it's painful to
watch for all of us and sad and
depressing and people in his family who
are allowing him to do this disgraceful
by the way but i think they're getting
ready to face somebody else in and i
think they're looking at those videos of
desantis listen ron desantis i moved to
florida as well because of desantis he
did everything that was the opposite of
what joe biden did and bill de blasio
did and gavin newsom did and everyone
and their brother sister mother neighbor
moved to florida if he's looking at
desantis and you know they are because
they already started going after it oh
that don't say a gay bill there's no
don't say gay bill they invented that
they did all of that because they're
terrified that a desantis or someone
like him could run and they know damn
well that joe biden cannot hold a candle
to that it's not gonna work so they're
starting to think who are we gonna need
to push up and i don't think people
should be excited about this because
i'll tell you joe biden is a conduit for
far left policies but what they're going
to be looking at post biden is someone
that's right there front and center
that's your far left that's someone
who's not going to need to be a conduit
because they're going to want to do it
all themselves and i'll remind you liz
talked about all those things that joe
biden could be doing to make things
better of course he could be doing that
leadership starts at the top the
destruction i will remind you is
intentional the destruction is
intentional they need you to be a
dependent they need you to be in poverty
they need you to lose your business
because when you do all of those things
guess who you're dependent on big daddy
government that's what they need those
are the people in society that they one
day get to control get to push a mandate
on and everybody just lays down and does
whatever they want to do so none of this
makes sense until you realize that they
could be doing but they're not doing on
purpose
jedidiah i said you swallowed a couple
extra red pills before now i'm pretty
sure you snorted them when i was on
video with john a second ago geez she
gets it man uh john to a lot of those
points um and i know you know a ton of
insiders in the swamp and dc area and
everything my feeling is they didn't
think that he was going to break down
this quickly i agree with jedidiah that
this is intentional this is a demolition
of of our economy and our all of our
structures and institutions so that
we'll you know sort of need them more in
their estimation but i don't think that
they thought he wouldn't make it four
years and that's becoming pretty obvious
again we're only a year and a half into
this thing with him
yeah look i mean they deluded themselves
though right guys
think about this we have a corporate
media that set the bar for then
candidate and now president joe biden
his his competency bar was set at oh wow
look he was able to order his own ice
cream chocolate chocolate chip i mean
this is where they set the bar for the
president of the united states but to
jedidiah's point i've been saying this
for well over a year year and a half 100
is correct this is all by design take
liz's point about fuel prices 100
we can open up oil and gas leases we can
increase drilling we've got the refining
capability
to refine as much oil as we bring them
out of the ground as much natural gas we
bring out of the ground but it's very
chilling when the ceo of chevron as he
said the other day says we may never see
another refinery built in the united
states that should kill everybody but
people unfortunately aren't students of
history and if you go back to 2009 1011
when obama was president
again the jedidiah's point about wanting
everybody on the public dole what did
obama do he declared war on the coal
industry we all knew that those were big
headlines the left-wing media loved it
the story they didn't tell is that while
he declared war on the coal industry he
and joe biden increased the output of
the coal leases on bureau of land
management land right so the u.s
government was making billions
as they were destroying private coal
producers they're going to do the same
thing here look i'm going to come out
and say it the democratic party the far
left radical communist democratic party
now wants to do to all americans what
they've done to black americans for
decade upon decade
keep them oppressed keep them in poverty
keep them in squalor and keep them
completely dependent upon government
jedi is right liz is right that is
exactly the end game
there is a theme to this friday show